[Music]
russia's invasion of ukraine has
prompted an unprecedented response from
the west
economic warfare the european union and
its partners are working to [ __ ]
putin's ability to finance his war
machine we are resolved to continue
imposing massive costs on russia western
sanctions have sent shock waves across
russia's economy the um ruble has sunk
to another record low but will it be
enough to stop putin our experts weigh
in
what sanctions have been imposed on
russia and how severe are they
one category is financial sanctions
there they've been various measures
targeting russian banks
uh a number of them have been blocked
from swift which is a messaging system
for cross-border payments and then on
top of the the banking sanctions there's
uh a number of measures involving
sovereign debt including restrictions to
secondary trading of of russian
sovereign debt and um
uh russian companies and banks have been
have had their access to to western
financial markets cut
but the biggest bazooka of all on the
financial front
is um the sanctions against the the
central bank of russia the third
category i'd say is measures targeting
um vladimir putin himself members of his
circle
and a number of oligarchs who are seen
as either being close to him or
supportive of the kremlin and you know
there we've seen asset freezes travel
bans and so on and the thing uh matthew
um i'm sure will agree with this is you
know the thing that really
made a big difference is this uh threat
to freeze the
630 billion dollars of
assets that the central bank holds
overseas
and that's really
the sort of safety net that
backstops entire economy what effect
have sanctions had so far and what's
likely to happen to the russian economy
the effect of sanctions is really to
create a kind of heart attack
in russia's financial system and that's
the first and most important effect so
you've seen the ruble
fall
as people worry about capital flight
worry that the central bank no longer
has the foreign assets it needs to
defend the currency the share prices
of russian
firms that are traded in moscow or
offshore have
collapsed including the banks and all of
that filters through into a kind of
generalized loss of confidence in the
financial system and there are cues of
russians
outside
bank branches across russia at the
moment beyond that i think a big
question mark is how much the energy
sector and trade in oil and gas is
affected by this
they have notionally been excluded from
the sanctions regime but the complexity
of dealing with russia in order to buy
russian oil gas seems to be putting a
lot of people off which is why the oil
price has now hit 110 dollars roughly
yeah i think that that's right patrick
and i'd add a couple of things to that
one is you know that um well according
to some estimates and what one one of
them is based on real-time data we're
seeing inflation spiking to to quite an
alarming level um by one estimate um 70
on an annual basis which is obviously
something to watch very closely and and
something that will um impact very
heavily on on ordinary russians um and a
broader point to make is that you know
this really
shows that the the strategy that russia
had the fortress russia strategy they
had as they called it which was to
insulate the economy from
sanctions which they they introduced
almost a decade ago after earlier
sanctions in relation to crimea that
that really looks like a potemkin
structure
it's crumbled away
what has russia's response been so far
what russia's sought to do
is try and invent a playbook
off the cuff to deal with having a major
financial crisis
uh on its hands and
the variety of stabilization
things that they've tried to do in the
financial markets to restore confidence
but there's not a magic bullet for them
because the bulk of their foreign assets
which is the backstop of the system are
under threat of being frozen the big
question is whether russia chooses to
escalate
not just in a military fashion which is
what it's doing in ukraine right now but
in an economic fashion against the west
it could try and curtail gas
exports to europe that's a real pressure
point or a various specialist metals
where russia's exports are pretty
important at global supply chains or
cyber attacks could be another uh tool
attacking western uh economic rather
than military interests in terms of the
the the um economic retaliation it's
been very muted so far i mean one of the
only things that russia has done is to
um
to
announce a tit-for-tat ban on um planes
from a number of countries using its
airspace and um
and and using its airports and um
interestingly um if
russia does manage to
take full control of ukraine
it could hold back things like rare
gases which ukraine is a big supplier of
and which are used in the manufacture of
semiconductors they're they're important
in um semiconductor etching so that's
just one example of a lever it could
pull um
[Music]
on on the basis of taking control of
ukraine if it manages to do that will
economic warfare help to stop putin
i don't think anyone including western
leaders and officials um thought that
sanctions alone would persuade vladimir
putin to pull his troops out of ukraine
i don't think anyone was naive enough to
think that um
you know even
dramatic financial sanctions would would
on their own do that
but sanctions are about several things
really uh and you know one is i suppose
on a basic level just showing that
there's a cost to be paid
um that if you're um you know if you
engage in in something as reckless as as
as you know invading a neighboring
country that
you're going to pay a price the glass
half empty view on this sanctions have
already kind of failed they they failed
to deter the invasion of
of ukraine and will probably fail
uh to uh lead russia to to you know end
that invasion and and
retreat back uh within its own borders
but i think the glass um half full uh
view is rather different and it's that
uh in the short term uh sanctions
change the incentives potentially of
russia's leadership and mr putin
and that
it creates a dynamic where if they scale
back the violence in ukraine
there can be a reciprocal scaling back
partial scaling back of economic
sanctions so it gives the west an
ongoing lever with which to
try to influence russia's behavior and
it may be that that lever yields results
if it does not and russia continues on
its path of action in ukraine causing
devastation then sanctions still have a
different function which is to
significantly weaken russia's economic
capabilities and in the end that will
have a significant impact on its
military capabilities over time
thank you for watching
for more of our coverage on ukraine
please click on the link and don't
forget to subscribe